so i'm going to start with the most
serious question
um when did you decide that you wanted
to own
july 2nd in terms of werewolves within
and the tomorrow
one morning i woke up and a piece of
paper flew into
my my bedroom window and in the window i
like looked up
and it said july 2nd and it said yours
and i was like well then i'll take it
congrats on having two you know cool
movies coming out on the same day
uh before we jump into into tomorrow war
um you did a few episodes of the office
early in your career what was that like
for you
uh being getting to be on that set
uh well it was really incredible like
one of my first ever
television gigs uh before that i'd done
uh like like five minutes or like not
even five minutes a
literally a minute long spot in the the
fourth season of arrest development
but the office was my
first time being like on a tv set and
being there consistently i did like a
seven episode run so i got to learn so
much about how
tv works uh like watching producers and
writers come in with notes
watching performances for tv kind of get
replayed and like
how you know watching how cameras pick
up these things
it was such a wonderful experience and
to get to do it on the office
tremendous uh one of the things that's
interesting about the tomorrow war
um is that i think you break the record
for any movie in terms of saying the
word [ __ ]
um you i think you set a new record
so whose idea was it that you were gonna
break the all-time record
uh it was my idea cause i was like i bet
i can do this like
i was like i bet i can i like i want to
see how
why keep it up also just like sort of
like the pad like [ __ ]
and even what you see in the thing is
like cut up a little bit but i'd do that
for like four
stories and chris was like that's a
great idea let's do it and like he loved
it so much
chris the director chris mckay uh
so what i want is for somebody to do put
like a counter
and like like they did for south park
with that episode where they were
like doing all the swears i wanted i
want to counter for how many times i've
said it because i
i really it was such a rapid fire i i
have no idea even how many times
uh the thing about the film is that it's
obviously a very serious
like it's dealing with serious stuff but
you're one of the reason like you're
part of the levity of the film when you
were looking at the script and you
talking to chris was it sort of made
clear like we need you to provide
you know like some humor to break up the
seriousness
yes uh i think like i think that's part
of what they were
what they wanted me in it for of course
uh
is is to sort of be like a heart to the
movie
and to sort of be a a
a a pressure valve you know
a release valve for these stakes
and uh you know i think the character
kind of got reworked a little bit as we
went through the script
and like as as it went so
he became a little bit bigger of a role
and
you know i think you sort of need him to
be for for that
because he he he's not only is he the
comedy of it but he's also a little bit
truly what most people would be in that
world
you know what i mean uh because because
the premise being that people who are
unprepared for war
and our everyday people bus drivers
chefs all the things are thrust into
this the highest stakes that any humans
ever been in it's
fighting aliens in the future you know
so
sort of him getting to like comment on
his surroundings in this
scenario is like defense mechanism and
also
a great thing to like sort of reset
these stakes
and like you know release some pressure
in the movie
completely one of the things i found
about this movie and which surprised me
uh was that it pulls the bad boys too
where i thought it was ending but no
that was just the end of the second
chapter
you know what i mean i sort of talked it
does
pull a bad boy's head boys too
absolutely one of my favorite movies
mind you
and i think it's a fun fun thing uh when
you
first saw jk simmons on set did you
think
why are any of us in this movie because
he can beat all the aliens on his own
on his own yeah i know and i was like
are you sure he was like i'm taking a
break
and he like flicked the cigarette it hit
uh
a
fuse to a keg of dynamite and it
exploded and he like kind of like lit a
cigarette on it i was like
you need a second cigarette but he was
like yeah
i don't even smoke i was like cool he
was [ __ ] huge
he's chiseled he's just that's
commissioner gordon the the buffett's
commissioner gordon we've ever seen
uh and he he
he's so cool and he's so
interesting and fun and like funny to
talk to
between scenes because he's got like
amazing stories
like amazing theater stories amazing
film stories amazing television stories
and then like when it comes to like
action he's playing this thing
he can switch and he's like the most
intense he's like really truly
you know he is my tempo uh you didn't
pull a chris farley remember when you
did that movie
that was really i did do that i did do
that
even i even went badly remember when you
did guys and dolls
that was great i was like remember when
you did
commissioner gordon i legit did that he
was very patient with me so i
appreciated it
uh before before i run out of time with
you uh i'm a huge fan of uh
lord and miller and i am really looking
forward to the uh the after party
which sounds completely different than
anything i've seen um so can you talk a
little bit about that project
and what it's about absolutely uh the
tomorrow war was a uh
you know uh lord miller show coming
apple tv plus
uh it's about uh uh chris miller wrote
directed uh the thing uh it's
it stars me tiffany haddish zoe chao
alana glazer jamie dimitro uh
ben schwartz dave franco all star cast
uh and me uh but uh it's about
it's a high school reunion
who done it murder mystery whodunit
uh where people are recalling a
uh an event of a night a murder but
they're all telling it through
their own lens and each lens being a
different
genre of film uh it's a really cool
concept a really fun show
really fun to work on i'm really excited
for the show i'm confident the scripts
were good
scripts were brilliant and like and like
the concept alone but the execution of
the concept i'm really excited for
people to see it
uh you also get to be part of marvel's
modoc uh
and uh uh which you know is obviously
awesome
um talk a little bit about getting to be
part of that and how much did you pay to
be on it
uh like a hundred thousand but i think
it was a bargain
uh 100k but it's in installments so i'm
you know i'll be able to pay that down
eventually
uh it was really great to get to uh
to be on there i got to be on [ __ ]
because like like when i said
a phone call with with jordan blumen and
jeff loeb and i was like
what i'm a comic nerd i'm a you know i'm
a
i'm a marvel nerd i'm a dc nerd but in
the case of this i'm a marvel nerd
uh so to get to be part of like and
knowing
modoc from comics i was like this is
such a great idea for how to use this
character
and you know i'm friends with patton uh
and he's so funny
like what a perfect uh sort of like
pairing
and to get actually and in it i get to
play gary uh
the loyal aim uh henchman
uh and it's such a fun kind of role to
get to play because
because it's it's sign up kind of in my
wheelhouse to play like the
the the unflappable uh helper
you know but they get to do that in like
an animated space in
the world of marvel was a a dream
what are you getting ready to do what's
coming up for you uh so i've got a movie
coming out the same time
it's called werewolves within uh it's a
horror comedy
uh thriller uh mystery movie
uh uh it's kind of ifc written by
mission wolf directed by josh rubin
really great
fun funny scary movie i'm really excited
for that
and right now i'm shooting a movie
called senior year in atlanta uh with
rebel wilson and zoe chow
again and mary holland uh it's a really
funny movie
uh i'm gonna say congrats on all the
success i wish you nothing but the best
thank you for giving me your time
oh my absolute pleasure and i think you
should leave season two
uh july 8th